Texas deals with the Border crisis Joe
Biden he took a quick trip North to
Wisconsin you as usual you know mumbling
bumbling stumbling and slurring his
words Whispering into the microphone uh
yelling getting confused as he always is
and then lying about the economy just
like he lies about the border for three
years being secure and closed take a
look Tim thank you for the introduction
I got to met I got to meet his Twins and
his wife and uh no wonder he's here
I tell you what they're going keep him
here and thanks to the outstanding
Senators Tammy Ballwin Wisconsin
tamy and Amy katar and Tina Smith from
the state of
[Applause]
Minnesota if I have all three of them on
my side I don't worry about anything I'm
proud to announce $ 1 billion from the
bipartisan infrastructure law will be
used to build this new bridge by the way
used to make the beer brewed here it is
used to make the Brew beard in
this oh Earth Rider thanks for the great
lakes I wonder why he's my professor uh
well I won't get into my
professor but look my predecessor though
he chose a different course they're
still making 350% profit it cost 10
bucks to make it 10 bucks to make
it it's like listening to great great
great grandpa rambling anyway Biden then
took a fun picture with Amy kachar at a
local bar but apparently put on his hard
hat backwards meanwhile the American
people they suffering the effects of
Biden inflation Biden's High interest
rates but the left they seem to only
care about personal attacks some of the
most repulsive vitriol directed at
Senator Tim Scott take a look Tim Scott
was behind Donald Trump the entire time
grinning like a shire Cat last night
what did you think about the Tim Scott
moment on
the stage with
Trump I mean I've called this the the
great
emasculation of the Republican party I
know Tim and I are both practicing
Christians but I don't know if he could
pray like that to to the other side I
mean it was humiliating to watch what
Tim Scott did Tim Scott he's this big
man what is he so afraid of what are
they so afraid of is Donald Trump going
to punch him in the nose you know if he
doesn't suck up to him like that I mean
there's plenty of job all right there's
a lot more here now to respond South
Carolina Senator Tim Scott you know
Senator um identity groups in America
you're not allowed to attack them but
there seems to be open season on one
group conservative African-Americans I'm
sure you're sick and tired of it because
I certainly am uh some of these comments
are
repulsive absolutely they are vile and
disgusting comments coming from the far
left Sean the most racist in the country
are liberals the bigotry that comes from
the far radical left it's just normal
these days why because they're trying
not just to attack me but they're trying
to make sure that any other minority who
will think for themselves and consider
the GOP they want to send a message to
every single one of them step out of
line and we'll attack you too that level
of intimidation doesn't work with me and
to every single African American
Hispanic Millennial anybody in the
majority population or minority
population if you believe in
conservatism stand up and be counted if
you want to make America the greatest
nation on God's green earth Step Into
the Fire because we have to save this
nation we better save it right now
because the radical left they're so
afraid of people like me people like you
Sean thinking for ourselves speaking out
and speaking the truth that they will do
anything they possibly can to silence
the truth but it doesn't work with me
it's not going to work with
others you you're going to be on
anybody's short short list to be a
potential vice president of our country
that's just a fact is this a means of
just trying to intimidate you threaten
you or maybe they're threatened by you
just asking they are certainly
threatened by me absolutely Sean they're
threatened by me and they're th
threatened by people like me here's what
they refus to say they refused to say
the truth under Joe Biden crime in
devastated neighborhoods crime in
impoverished neighborhoods crime in
black neighborhoods has
skyrocketed when you remove when you
defund the police disrespect the police
what do you expect we've seen
Devastation after Devastation in big
liberal Democratic city after big
liberal Democrat City what they're
asking for for is the same thing
conservatives are asking for a
restoration of Law and Order they want
more policing not less policing these
are law-abiding citizens that under Joe
Biden crime is high inflation is high
unemployment is devastating you can't
even afford to buy a house in biomics so
you add together high crime High
inflation low opportunities and
minorities Millennials and women all
looking to our party for hope we're
bringing it GOP coming your way by way I
I just happen to know you personally I
know that this engagement has been a
long time coming I'm not going to give
out any more information than that um
and they're even attacking you on that
and it's pretty disgusting they should
be ashamed of themselves but I don't
think they have shame uh we're very
happy for you and Senator we' love
having you congratulations hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else